espace de rééducation podologue et
kinésithérapeutes 18 professionnels de
santé réunis en un seul lieu
la maison de santé pluridisciplinaire de
guyancourt mille mètres carrés au coeur
du quartier de villas roi un projet qui
devrait permettre de lutter contre la
désertification médicale à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines royal chute
démographique des médecins et
deuxièmement est aussi une augmentation
des charges les médecins ce qui fait
qu'ils sont poussés à se rassembler il
faut qu'ils changent leur organisation
donc c'est une réponse pour que nos
citoyens ou une réponse de leur médecin
plus rapide vous savez qui n'a pas été
confronté à avoir un rendez vous à trois
mois pour un point médecins spécialistes
c'est en effet un mode d'exercice qui
pourraient médecin est beaucoup plus
satisfaisant car il permet de nombreux
échanges et qui pour le patient facilite
également les choses puisqu'il permet
une bien meilleure coordination du
parcours de soin initié en 2009 cinq
années de travail ont été nécessaires
pour créer cette structure avec l'aide
de saint quentin en yvelines l agence
régionale de santé
guyancourt a pu la mettre en service dès
septembre 2017
mais si les premiers mois sont
concluants pour ce professionnel le
combat contre la pénurie de médecins
n'est pas encore gagné on sait bien sûr
que la pénurie elle vient de la
diminution des numerus clausus pendant
20 ans par rattraper avec des maisons de
santé le la pénurie médicale qui existe
il faut lui reste juste à réaugmenter
depuis 2005 partir de 2020 ça va aller
mieux selon le ministère de la santé le
principal problème est avant tout la
répartition surtout en zone rurale afin
d'attirer les jeunes professionnels
d'autres maisons de ce type devraient
voir le jour dans les prochaines années
notamment à plaisir